Please welcome from our LA studio,
it's Michaela Watkins.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
Hi, how are you?
This Diane Keaton look that you have today
is so wonderful, and it makes me so happy.
Well, fun fact about this outfit,
I had planned to wear another pair of pants with it
that I premiered the show with,
but I couldn't fit in them because I've gained weight,
since the beginning of the show,
because I do think I've gone
a little bit back to stress eating and-
Oh, I know that song, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I literally, I could fit in the pants,
but I looked like a sausage that was being stepped on.
(Michaela laughs)
So I was like, I guess we'll go with that other size
of the other pants.
So thank you.
I'm glad you like it 'cause I had like a horror moment.
I think you look really lovely.
Oh, thank you.
First of all, I was watching you on Colbert.
I'm not exactly sure when the episode was
that you went outside to the restaurant across the street.
When was that?
It was my first time I went on his show
and I was so excited because the David Letterman theater
was across the street from this restaurant
I used to be a waitress at,
and it was really a miserable time.
And I used to like wistfully look at people
going to see David Letterman,
And I would do like the silverware roll-ups the whole time,
and just be like, "One day, one day."
And it was a really awful restaurant,
like, the management staff was so mean and nasty
to the waitstaff.
So I got to have this real moment
where I got to go on Colbert,
and then we went across the street
and flipped them the bird.
Is that the part you're talking about?
It's the greatest thing I've ever seen.
But in fairness, I was imitating a waitress
who had gotten her,
like, a big movie or something like that,
and she came in and flipped us all off
and said, "I'm out of here."
So, and then she-
You know what?
I think that moment means so much to me because I feel like
we relate to those kinds of moments in life.
Not only do we all want to do them,
we'd all love to just do the, ah, you.
But it's the way you did it
that was so charming and relatable.
It's so,
I just related to it so much.
It's how I would handle a situation myself.
And it was so refreshing-
We could open a studio where people can come
and we can do this kind of like projection, right?
Where we get them on the hologram,
and then we just say,
"What would you like to say to your brother?"
By the way, I do think
that we could open an online academy
of you get to go back to places and times
and people in your life and have that button.
Yes, yes, the one that you stay up all night going,
reworking the monologue that you would have said.
Like, do you remember the movie Tootsie?
Ah, it's the best movie ever.
The best movie ever.
Do you remember when Tootsie yells at the boss like,
"It's not Toots or Tootsie or Honey or Baby or Darling.
It's Dorothy, capital D-O-R-O-T-H-Y, Dorothy."
And like goes on this whole thing.
And we all have that thing where I'm like in my mind, going,
we walk around trying to be so nice,
and then we go home and we're like,
"Okay, here's what I should have,
no, here's how I should have said it.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, no, this,
this is what I would've said, and another thing," you know?
and then-
Okay, so Michaela,
let's open an online academy
where you can live out your fantasy
that when you didn't get the moment
to say what you really wanted to say-
I love this.
So let's start an academy of getting that moment back
with total preparation and catharsis.
Yes, oh my God, I love this idea.
Should we hug it out?
Yes, let's hug.
Okay.
Come here.
Okay, why do I look like I'm five feet taller than you?
I don't know, but I do need a hug-
And then we merged as one.
And now I control you (laughs).
I love this.
Now, you're also playing, you know,
not in character, not fully going for it physically,
but you know, an attractive, funny,
interesting woman on "The Unicorn".
Do you like playing that kind of a role?
I do, she's sort of like a toned down version
of some other stuff I've done because,
and that's what sort of the challenge
with Delia on "The Unicorn"
is that she is ferociously loyal and caring,
and I think very co-dependent
with the people she loves in her life, and wants,
and controlling, wants them to do well and succeed
and feels that her way is the best way.
So I wouldn't necessarily want to hang out
too much with Delia, but I appreciate the Delias.
And I think that is a balance
because I don't want her to be a caricature
where she goes all one way,
where she's just, you know,
giving marching orders to everybody.
But I think she's got,
I think it all comes from a place of so much, so much,
like too much love, you know?
And I can relate to that.
Michaela Watkins, I am such a fan.
"The Unicorn" airs Thursdays at 9:30/8:30 Central on CBS.
Thank you so much for coming here.
Thank you so much.
Give you a hug.
Yeah, one more now.
Yeah, now what's the-
Here we go.
Okay, I'm just gonna-
Wait, I've got to say over here,
and then just wrap my leg around you.
Oh my God, see?
We're the same person.
I wanted to wrap my leg around you, too.
(lighthearted music)